okay here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to cultural appropriations
[Music]
wow
[Music]
this fall
six cities
prepare
for two
rebels with a cause
[Music]
phoenix
houston
charleston national new york
baltimore
[Applause]
the rebels with a cause comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
strangers
[Music]
very glad to be with you
oh that's tasty yeah so we got a new tea
in there yeah
i feel like an effective jerk already uh
we have a lot to talk about today so
here's one thing a lot of people have
been asking many of you have been saying
hey people have been saying that uh you
know the president doesn't control gas
prices
that's
false there's more to it than that but
that statement itself is false fact
check
19 pinocchios and then
there's also been a shift you just had
the first ever mexican-born female um
congresswoman
congress z congress z
she'd be fine with women because she's a
lady
and there's a huge demographic shift
taking place here in the united states
now just to be clear i want to warn
everyone out there
that i am not advocating for open
borders at all i am not denying the
reality of demographic voting patterns
at all i'm just letting you know that
there's a silver lining and one that
could definitively tip elections in
certain states and it's a good thing
uh so we'll be talking about that also
we'll be talking about fat ladies and
horses you'll understand in a few
seconds
[Laughter]
but not on horses
[Laughter]
my question to you before i move on what
changes are you making as it relates to
gas prices are you making changes
because i i didn't even have an empty i
don't even have an empty tank and i went
and i filled it up it was 107.
the other day i just put it in my rectum
that yes yes
you're getting screwed either way yep
it's a weight loss it's like an animal
fun yeah even though those people do the
coffee enemas
hmm they're like yeah coffee on them is
it detox i just call it coffee with my
bottles yeah well
it's like doing the uh the coffee butt
chuck yes by the way fastest wit and the
west fastest man on his feet quickest
man on his feet and i will be on tour
with him him and i together
six cities huge venues we will be in
phoenix
houston
charleston west virginia ohio nashville
ahoy red bank because new york wouldn't
have us ahoy and baltimore baltimore
go to uh lottospider.com tour phoenix
has been selling out like uh not selling
out but selling like crazy
hot cakes yep and uh some people saying
why don't you do more than that because
we have to do if we want the show to go
on hiatus i would love to do i would
love to do shows every day every day i
would love to at some point look i'm
taking a two month break and just do 30
40 live shows but i can't do it
you can't please everybody all right and
gerald my best man how are you sir i am
well sir how are you i'm doing fine yeah
yeah you're not as pissed off today no
i'm optimistic i'm mad but optima it's a
consistent low-grade irritation yeah but
elon musk made you happy by elon musk
republican for the first
african-american voting republicans yeah
see
so uh before we get to that
we need to i don't know that we have a
former vice president uh joseph biden uh
he was talking about the economy at uh
an afl-cio convention convention
conference i don't know how they refer
to it and uh he did have uh he wasn't
really a stoic he had a tough time
controlling his emotions
which you know you reach that certain
age left brain right brain no brain
brings us to this week in biden if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or trump then you ain't
black why this guy guy left my my my
employment went to another job
because he got paid more
wall street didn't build this country
middle class built this country and
unions built the middle class
under my plan
last year
we cut the deficit by
350 billion dollars
i don't want to hear any more of these
lies
about reckless spending
we're changing people's lives
imagine
just imagine if you're in a situation
where
you're going to able to be in
a position where pay for preschool
for kids
i'm deadly earnest we're 55 of the
largest fortune 500 companies
made 40 billion
insurance company has to cover it it's
because of that law
zero
zero zero
zero
zero
in federal income tax let's continue to
give working families a fighting chance
face our challenges head on and let's
keep building a better america god bless
you all and may god protect our troops i
mean if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black
huh didn't realize the former vice
president was a white supremacist yeah a
lot of it too i think he just hit a few
threes that's it yeah yeah
by the way we also have a costume
contest tomorrow it's cultural
appropriations taiwan i love that i was
watching the view yesterday and what's
your name sunny uh not sunny liston
it's the only one i know sunny hostin
that's right sunny hosting the hostess
yeah it's basically it's basically a
synonymous sunny list and sunny hosting
put them in a lineup can't tell the
difference sunny hostin was talking with
uh joe behar this and yeah cause uh
donald trump is no spring chicken he's
78 and uh biden will be 81 and joe boy
goes and biden works out biden works out
every day a trump you look at him not so
much like yeah but donald trump isn't
mentally [ __ ] well he can strike a
sentence together and hold his bowels
very true yeah
which one of you crapped at the vatican
that would be biden yeah that'd be him
on the floor by the way praying to the
lord that he didn't but even god hates
him yep so
i got an indulgence for you joe
i used them all
i was hoping for zero poops no no
is this more purgatory time yeah
ah how did i get out of here no i need
to confess he thinks a conventional
booth is a porta potty st stop joe
just grabs like a pope hat or a cardinal
hat
oh yeah every time
everybody reaches for their hat they're
going
stop it joe i know what you want
it is not a bathroom
it's a hat ah i'm gonna go too all right
so this is something this is a so we've
talked about this in the past
we've talked about this in the past and
uh now we're seeing this come to
fruition and i wanna i want to get into
this i don't want to get too granular so
that you know your eyes glaze over but
uh the latino american hispanic american
the uh not latinx americans because i
would never pander them to them and i
don't want to get shanked
they hate that term latinx oh yeah uh
there really is a change and we've
always talked about how it makes sense
but now we've just seen on tuesday mayra
flores became the first republican to
win texas's 34th district since 1870. so
we have first republican since 1870 also
the first mexican-born congresswoman
here she is we are live here at myra
flores what's the difference
in candidate for congress district 34.
celebrating brown following her
congressional win tonight i spoke with
her earlier tonight where she shared her
thoughts about her candidacy
i see the potential in us we have all
the ingredients to be successful and i
just want to bring better jobs better
opportunities so our children don't have
to leave south texas for those
opportunities why can't we have that
here and i just think that we're worth
fighting for
now flores has garnered over 50 percent
of the vote meaning she will now assume
former rep representative philemon velas
seats she would only hold this seat
until january
can you say diversity higher um
by the way what are the readings
boom goes the dynamite yeah why did they
have that meeting at like a techno dance
club with all the lights yeah like what
what are you doing i love how no matter
how great technology gets we still can't
stop the delay in newscasters right
right yeah
just that awkward pause like
okay now we're here yeah now we're here
okay and can you tell us about what oh
i'm sorry you you go i was going to
speak you go
all right i was good i mean oh
it happened again okay i'm sorry i
cannot hear over the dancing music yes
there are chechnyan club goers i like to
party so the point is it was a horrible
place to host your victory party but
first mexican-born american uh
congresswoman yeah
mexican-born congresswoman she's now
american but not mexican-american she
was born in mexico you can't be born in
both i mean maybe if you were born right
in the middle of the border but i have
no idea yeah right on the fence because
i don't have a wall no
uh and uh first person to win republican
to win this district since the 1800s
now joe biden won this district keep in
mind at least
one
by four points hmm in 2022 four points
something before i get to the uh
the hispanic community
there's also a shift in the
african-american community as seen that
last night elon musk for the very first
time voted republican ah yeah he tweeted
out i voted for myra flores first time i
ever voted republican massive red wave
in 2022
and then when he was asked who he was
leaning toward in the 2024 presidential
race he responded just one word desantis
oh my gosh yeah i didn't even know about
that until we started looking at this
but by the way for him to say massive
red wave yeah like this is a guy who's
gonna take a lot of crap for that this
is okay with it yeah well this is a
perfect example of there can be no
intellectual consistency on the left
because no one passes the purity test
there would be
nobody who you could name who should be
more of a darling of the eco left the
neo-environmentalist left should have to
be
right it should have to be a musk and
even not too long ago they were saying
get an electric car
but now they hate him because he had to
move electric car facilities from
california to texas
think about that
if the left if their policies work as it
relates to encouraging green energy
they would all flock to california
they ca it can't be done there but it
can be done in texas all right
so uh here's something else that's
pretty important um she flipped
cameron county that's 85 percent
hispanic
now biden won that county by 13 points
in 2020 hillary clinton by 33
points geez wow 33 points
um
this is this is part of a large
tournament
yes well
supposedly yes i mean yes legit legit
most fair and balanced she dominioned
the vote
considering that democrats whole
strategy is getting hispanic voters to
turn out for them because they're
they're getting their butts kicked in
just about every other category that's
that's massive going from 33 up yeah 16.
well this is part of a nationwide trend
this is important for people to
understand and you'll hear people who
say demographics are destiny i
understand what they're talking about i
understand that um millions of illegal
immigrants flooding across the border
who are promised you know welfare
benefits who are promised a social
safety net that they haven't paid into
that that's a real problem i understand
that i am talking about hispanic voters
who
usually
usually have been here for you know
two generations removed or they migrated
here call it the last 10 20 years
there's a generational shift if you look
at it but 26 of hispanics right now
across the country uh approve of biden's
performance 26
that's low
compared to whites which is 31 percent
yeah they're that that's got to be
scaring the crap out of these guys it
seems high have you seen the guy right i
want to know who the 26 percent oh yeah
i think that's a really low number and
54 of hispanics disapprove of biden's
performance yeah yeah i would agree and
this is important uh hispanic democrats
they're 10 percent more likely to
consider just completely switching
parties than hispanic republicans yeah
so you're seeing a disapproval with
hispanic uh hispanic voters who are
democrats and you're seeing them
disapprove of biden's handling of the
economy and then there's the inherent
right the inherent values that you see
often with uh especially
latin american catholics yeah they're
not they're not democrats by nature
they've been promised free stuff for a
long time but once you're here you're
here legally and you're paying taxes you
go wait hold on a second maybe we need
people to sign the guest book yeah well
they've been promised free stuff as a
step to prosperity right the democrats
have been saying like we're going to get
you in we're going to get you here
you're going to have free stuff you're
going to get jobs you're going to be
able to do this and they're seeing that
that isn't happening and it has not been
happening historically for them the
democrats promises are falling short and
then they're seeing the social things
that they're like how in the world as a
big family culture like they are not for
all the stuff that democrats are pushing
right now and it's turning them away so
just keep doing what you're doing
democrats please i mean i don't even
think there's a spanish uh spanish words
for uh drag queen story hour i don't
they they're like i think it's no
yeah it's oh no the uh the bottomless
pit is that way ah this is uh
yeah cartel cartel
yes yes pretty soon your head is going
to be on a turtle yes you enjoy it
pick it up if
look i want you i would love to hear
from you below if you are uh you know
hispanic american uh
mexican-american south
american what i want to hear from you is
what issue
would there be that you think you can
have them comment below uh what issue
would there be you can be a little
quicker to the draw there two minutes on
that if i just i don't want to say
comment below
i don't need to say comment or question
of the day
he's like you need to say comment below
i will not do it unless i won't
he will test you and you will not hit
the trigger
hold hold
and then later when i'm too segmented
no genuinely what what issue would there
be that you inherently think hispanic
voters would be attracted to on with the
democratic platform when i have the son
of a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
when i have these conversations
uh
sorry cnn is distracting me they're
showing biden as though his speech
yesterday was great right would i have
conversations with suspect what are you
going to have a conversation with a
hispanic american like oh yeah you know
and hey isn't it horrible that uh you
know people here have the ability to get
guns see get guns yes here to protect
isn't it horrible that you can't have
abortions up until birth no it's uh
jesus say that's killing babies can you
believe that they're not taxing people
more i don't like taxes
there's no issue that i can think of or
they would inherently be a democrat
yeah
no i i really don't see them winning for
this uh with any of the plans that they
have put out so far and i i i know that
we're still a little bit of a ways away
and right now it's a little bit early to
see this congresswoman that we're
talking about is only holding her seat
until january until there's another
uh election cycle for this this is kind
of a special election but
i really want to see
more of these kinds of results to just
show you the first person a republican
because we're called the party that's
racist right right that's holding
everyone here's the thing you see a
trend right donald trump uh was 29 he
won the hispanic vote in 2016. 32 in
2020. that's the most for a republican
since
2004. now do the math on that okay he
won 32 of hispanic vote if you're
looking at these trends people who
disapprove who approve you don't need to
win republicans don't need to win the
hispanic vote but if you reduce that
margin to let's say you get 40 percent
maybe 42 percent
republicans don't lose another election
ever not to mention in local elections
particularly in states like texas and
states like arizona that is a huge
difference and that's why you know i do
when people vilify the wrong people the
people we should be mad at are suburban
white pitches that's true pretty much
but you just said those states think
about california think about their
hispanic population and how that can
change california yep if if that ever
happens republicans run the board there
is no contest and everybody yes and
here's the thing that they're the least
likely uh voting block to get out and
vote so if you make this shift and then
you re you encourage them to vote yeah
meaning legal citizens of course we most
of them by the way support voter id
legal immigrants that's another thing
it's over 70
of hispanic americans if you get this
shift you win them by let's say 40
something percent not win them but just
reduce your margin of loss
and you get more of them out to vote
that's a huge difference that's a big
big big big change now if you could do
the same thing and just reduce your
losses with uh you know uh upper middle
class of urban white women to you know
like win
10 of them you know what just get uh get
fifty percent of them more
to work
just have free wines the day of the
election get them a job
they can pay taxes
how about that how about them apples
suffragettes so um
in 2022 also this is important to know
donald trump flipped zapata county in
south texas for the first time in 100
years
june 2021 mcallen texas 85 hispanic
there they elected their first
republican mayor in 24
years now
here's something else
and you should always assume that your
your opponent is
smart uh and be pleasantly surprised
when they're not
assume that aoc
is a genius assume that she is a member
of mensa and you'll never have a problem
with her that's a that's a that's hard
well i'd say i know it makes me more
upset yeah i know
i feel like there should be a qualifier
that you can't be a member of mensa if
you're that googly no you can't not with
those crazy eyes no it's like they were
hold on a second are those realized did
you buy them at michael's why are they
so big now uh aoc is a perfect example
how the left is also doing our work for
us they're turning off latinos they're
turning off hispanics for example by
using terms like latinx which no
hispanic americans like
i also have a mini rant about this
because there are some politicians
including democratic politicians that
rail against the term latinx and they're
like this is so bad this is so bad for
the party like blah blah blah
and like it's almost as though it has
not struck some of these folks that
another person's identity is not about
your re-election prospects
this is what so first off i don't know
if
maybe a bright idea could strike her and
by that i mean a man uh last name idea
first name bright kidding
mr idea mr idea go ahead i see you've
come back again mr bright ow ow
this time the brass knuckles
i bet you if she i bet you if she fell
down a well her eyes would go
straight back i don't know oh man it's
kicked by a mule went across again
so she says it's not about your
re-election someone else's identity okay
irony alert
only three percent or less of hispanics
say that they use the term or even like
it so she's speaking and by the way she
also speaks for the extinct people of of
of uh puerto rico she also speaks for
the native americans and by the way that
just includes all the above the cheyenne
the apaches of lakota you know people
who are war with each other she speaks
for all of them and now she speaks for
hispanics saying i just you know
republicans just do you understand
someone else's identity well why do you
get to choose that to be the identity
when 97
of the people in question think you're
full of crap and by the way miss go down
to a parking lot and have a photographer
go with you to decry these cages you're
telling me that somebody's saying hey
latinx isn't great for the party you
pander to everyone right you try to go
and get votes by staging pictures like
you actually give a damn and you don't
yeah so let's not be holier than thou so
where was she when the cages were put
there oh she was attending bar i think
oh right yes
she was at latinx salsa night well would
you even trust her to make a drink
you know that's a fair question i mean
honestly i'd sooner drink with bill
cosby yeah
i would sooner have a drink with bill
cosby go up to the restroom for 20
minutes to give him plenty of time to
roofing me and then come back yes
exactly you both end up screwed it
doesn't really matter right exactly but
you know she's screwing her constituency
so the point is either way you end up
screwed
that's what i'm saying yeah well she's
worried about getting her majority like
we just learned this yeah by doing
wonders
keeping high wages out of her district
yeah getting no no shut up shut up shut
up guys shut up because it's a winning
strategy keep high wages out of our
district and keep using the term latinx
can we get a four aces aoc by the way
neria nary a large organization dollar
right get money out of politics there's
no way that that's what's happening with
aoc if you have this disconnector you go
how in the hell can a functionally
[ __ ] googly-eyed crazy lady went
well you know what follow the money
trail because if it doesn't make sense
it's because it doesn't make sense but
what do i know i'm not one of the three
percent who identify as latinx
just me
dave x
oh gosh can we all start going by that
sounds like a horrible band you know gen
x s x this is the band x yeah oh yeah i
forgot was it static x and then became x
yeah i think so but they were x
x that's the sign not to mention
go and give it to you hey this is a live
show monday through thursday at 10 a.m
eastern if we are not here on youtube
best place to watch it is mug club
livewithcrowder.com we'll have a promo
tomorrow we do an extra full hour of
show we'll be playing what's in the box
today and i don't know what's in the box
which means we can't play it on youtube
and of course if you want to watch the
free show you can uh go to rumble uh
here's a story that you know you're an
animal lover and so am i dead very much
so two dogs love them so this was a
problem for us an animal shelter in
california has announced that it will
not give out pets
to second amendment supporters
yeah and this is what they said they
said we do not support those who believe
that the second amendment gives them the
right to buy assault weapons
if your belief are not in line with ours
we will not
adopt a pet to you now of course the
initial response
and i don't want to say rightfully so is
that these people are [ __ ] right
but upon further look we are willing to
obviously concede and hopefully find
common ground most of the gun statistics
that you have out there are bs for
example that your gun is more likely to
be used against you well that's not true
but as it relates to this their concerns
are understandable
there is a serious problem with
irresponsible gun owners
who have guns in the home
with pets it's true
[Music]
get a trigger lock
come on guys come on better than this
when that dog won that chocolate lab
adorable it was yeah chocolate get a gun
safe come on
man i can't imagine i actually you know
what this is something that happened to
me there was a dog named mr big before i
got hopper yeah before i got joe lewis i
worked with and he was a big uh american
bulldog pit bull probably mix i don't
know he was very but maybe great dane
maybe he's not hungry smoking gangsters
exactly played a lot of poker yes
um and i worked at a no-kill shelter in
michigan and everyone was afraid of this
dog this actually everyone was terrified
of this dog because he would just he
would be jumping up on the cage at the
kennel turned out he just didn't get get
a lot of attention because people were
afraid of him so i would open it up he
was the sweetest dog the most
affectionate he was just didn't learn to
not jump in excitement yeah and uh i
volunteered at the shelter for a while
and i said you know what he's older he's
nine years old no one else was going to
take him i said i feel like i know how
to handle him i've been working with him
for a couple months i would love to uh
adopt him and the person who ran the
shelter knew about my politics and said
i would never give you any dog from here
that's wasted wow
i might just i mean i still think about
it i mean i know he's probably passed
now but it made me sad for a very very
long time because this dog is just
everyone else is afraid of him i'm
willing to take him you're going to let
politics i also might have offended her
uh when they showed the dog training
video
and you know this is how you do this is
how you look for body language and at
the end she goes what did you think of
the training video i said well you got
to love that uh that mid-90s saved by
the bell font
is that all you noticed that's all you
notice with the font
i mean comic sans come on no it's not
all i noticed
uh i was trying to make a conversation
learned about the ears and the tail and
the body rigidity
get her
she wouldn't give me the dog oh my gosh
well that's so stupid by the way for
them to say hey if you're a second
amendment believer they they didn't say
what they really wanted to say there
this this is saying you want to buy
assault rifles like yeah if you want
guns at all they said assault rifles but
i mean if you think you should be able
to own a gun period
we're not going to give a dog to you if
you have a dog that's deemed dangerous
wouldn't it be better that you're a
second amendment you would think so just
in case not only that think about this
for a second yeah people who have
firearms more likely to be hunters
you've heard of hunting dogs these are
people who are far more likely to use
dogs for their intended purpose unlike
someone with a strap-on at drag queen
story hour who do you think is more
likely to abuse a duck do they have a
policy on that hey look we're sorry if
you uh fall into the category of a 41
attempted suicide rate because of what
was previously diagnosed as mental
illness we're not going to give you a
dog instead it's just you own an
inanimate object no dog for you i would
actually wager no one's going to run
these numbers uh that dog that uh
firearm owners probably make far better
oh yeah dog owners you know why because
they're not the st
when you see a woman with a stupid
little dog who's yapping and they pick
it up and reward that behavior
you're going that's not a gun owner
no that can't possibly be yeah how do
they find out anyway do they have like a
checklist of like hey do you support the
second amendment how is that even
legal for them to ask
i can't even ask if someone who works
here is a mormon
no that's fair i ask it's a yes it's a
yes
we love you
bro don't send us hate mail
this happened the other day where i was
making a joke about mormon raptors
because it was the utah raptor yeah and
then i realized i had someone i was like
i was like i'm sorry i didn't mean it
you know what do you mean it was like it
was like we had like a raptor like with
like a holy underwear he was like that's
funny i don't care i joked remember the
moab bomb i was like can we drop this
somewhere in utah and they were like hey
and i was like no i meant like because
there's not a lot of stuff in a lot of
places and it wouldn't hurt anybody yeah
didn't they let off bombs there for a
while well i think like tested them in
sections i don't know it sounds about
right okay before we move on to gas
prices yeah
before well you're gonna love this next
one because uh i mean this requires a
panoramic lens this
curve model uh famous tick talker rainey
bader was uh just recently this is a
story it's been making the rounds the
latest outrage i don't know if you know
this obese is now considered a slur just
like yesterday was respect now is obese
but when they say they're living their
truth unfortunately sometimes that truth
doesn't coincide with reality of weight
limits she was kicked out of a ranch for
being too heavy
[Music]
this is her video
it says shout out to deep hollow ranch
and montauk for making me leave because
i weigh over 240.
her music
yeah not ours yeah her music i don't
know why she added the rocky what's the
victory
no i think it's because she's a
heavyweight i think it says it's the
first
it's rocky road
then later she's she has a lot she has a
what is it alone in the ring overture
later she brings she's just a fan of
rocky music she gets on a clydesdale
by the way she's living her truth in
several other people's truth as well
[Laughter]
she has a trashcan robot
they have her on an ox there's no easy
way out
there's no shortcuts home you see a
crushed pony in the corner
just like that dog it's just a cow
jumping up against
that's a huge [ __ ]
and by the way most disappointed by this
uh black guy centaurs so that's yeah
they were oh man yeah not thrilled yeah
now missed opportunities
and you weren't kicked out you were just
told you couldn't run you were told you
couldn't ride that horse because it
requires a spine
they'd like it to not be suffered yes
the horse all the sudden spoke and told
us
where
we just had people who wouldn't give
dogs to second amendment owners we're
the animal cruelty advocates here by the
way you know who else would be kicked
not kicked out but not allowed to right
i weigh 240 pounds yeah so they'd be
like hey you probably can't i wouldn't
go oh
i also wouldn't you know throw a fit and
make a tick tock about it either yeah go
get the uh go get the space odyssey
theme do a video anybody would i can
barely get on one and i'm sure right now
it's just dave not reaching the stirrups
and chariots of fire playing like why
like the music selection it's just a
hype thing yeah
people don't want a step ladder can you
this is one of those things can you
believe that they wouldn't let me ride
the horse
yes yeah absolutely of course yeah they
didn't want to shoot it in the face
after exactly turn it to glue exactly
you know what we'll uh actually we have
a horse for you elmer come over here
yeah
so
he's got wonky aoc eyes
except he's much smarter but he's
charming did better on the mensa test
[Laughter]
so here's something i will say the
employee of the ranch and this is a
problem with social media this is uh one
of the employees of the ranch a young
person allegedly the owner's son
not a good response back in the day this
would have been a private dust up but
now it lives on forever responded to
bader's video
[Laughter]
when you're not a fat [ __ ] you can ride
a deep olive ranch
okay he's been drinking a little bit
yeah and working around animals that's a
good comment yeah exactly yeah
i mean look he's not wrong he's not
wrong but that's
back in the day you would have made that
mistake as a kid you would have talked
hey don't do that we're sorry here's a
free gift certificate so you can go ruin
the horses at the ranch over one
you're just not here we're going to
order a giant clydesdale yes exactly
when we find a species that can hold you
we'll call you back yeah once they're
retiring the budweiser horses you're
like you can have this other one
again we were going to send it to coors
yeah there's a dinosaur ranch that's
just right for you
so she just gets on the skeleton yeah
bones just fall through like sonic so
deep hollow ranch they addressed the
situation on facebook they said we would
like to apologize to anyone who this
offended well look that was clearly
meant to
offend and we do not condone or agree
with any part of that employee's video
that should be enough yeah
i agree with some parts
right
i mean i agree with the the the
biological argument yeah not so much the
nomenclature yeah drinking and being an
idiot is not uh right yeah
and you shouldn't broadcast no so here's
the thing the backlash though now has
been unbelievable the event organizer
cut ties with the ranch saying we will
not work with deep hollow ranch again
inclusivity and kindness are rooted in
our foundation and social media also
called for uh for uh spamming them with
one star yelp reviews i hope your
business has a plan b
shut this place down take deep hollow
ranch down and by the way the ranch's
website they have this listed that a
rider of baiter size would require
at least a 1200 pound horse oh wow
[Laughter]
and they have a list
they have a list for uh they have a list
of courses for riders over 250 and at
the top they act they literally have
clydesdale
don't exactly have a lot of clydesdales
hanging out for you to ride by the way
the organizer of this was hampton water
rose owned by john bon jovi's son their
co-founder they actually came into my
shop when they were trying to promote
this this was them trying to do an event
with influencers what's really funny is
the picture she posted of all the
influencers are like incredibly skinny
girls in the car and her standing next
to the car yeah i just thought it was a
little was she riding the car
there are weight limits for all kinds of
she was riding two metro geos like skis
look she's she's a bigger girl i get it
but she should she should have just said
hey i'm sorry i can't ride the horses
because i'm too big i mean that it
didn't seem like it needed to be a thing
this is the problem when you don't
believe in science you believe in the
science meaning whoever your religious
leader is at that point i mean that's
really fouchy was an el ron hubbard for
a couple of years so you believe in
thus science but you don't believe in
science well this is my truth i'm i'm
i'm a woman okay but you're not you if
you go to a doctor reality is going to
hit you in the face and he's going to
have to ask you well huh a second did
you you pissed hot for a pregnancy
doctor reality you pissed hot for
pregnancy oh you have prostate you have
testicular cancer right that's the
reality but i identify as a woman so it
means i'm pregnant no it doesn't well
look fat is just as healthy and it's
just as beautiful okay look maybe some
people find it just as beautiful you
know the people who will pay you like
900 to eat a cheeseburger on a webcam
they love that that's fine that's your
truth but it's not the truth of the
weight limit on another living being a
horse but the problem is how do you say
it when people get to this point we
laugh about it but if you say all bodies
are the same
there's everything as healthy
all of us you do get to a point where
you can't live
what is effectively a delusion
until you hit a fork in the road and at
this point she just she wants an actual
fork and she gets tired she's gonna eat
she's gonna use the fork that snack
your balls have ovarian cancer yes ah
there you go
those those testicles have
endometriosis well i just don't
i mean i think any time you shouldn't
even talk about it it's just it's it's
just difficult it's like look you're too
big for the horse
i'm sorry
be an adult about it yes well the guy
immediately crying like can you believe
this ranch has rules
she was saying and i read a little bit
more into the story she was saying oh
you didn't post this on your website
well when you walk up and they go
hey how much do you weigh
right you're a very large if i walk up
and they go sir how much do you weigh
and i'm like oh 240. oh the horse we
can't we can't do that they can't you
know they can't support the weight
okay
that sucks i wish i would have known i
mean maybe i'm mad that they didn't post
it but i'm not going online and going
they're fed shaming me i can't believe
it yeah it's almost like if you get on a
plane with her and she's like i'm 115
and i got to be like i'm 683 pounds
right yes
i need two seats just to average it out
it's just it's
not all this it's sorry you can't ride a
horse what is it
rules ranch is that what it is it's
rules ranch go to the budweiser ranch
yes exactly when did fat become a
protected class pizza pizza
when when everyone
you are a child
and we love you
i guess when half of america became a
protected class yeah that's true
straight white male not so much
everything else yes yeah i mean look
arnold schwarzenegger wouldn't be able
mr olympia wouldn't be able to get on
there this is it's just it's a weight
issue you can still say that fat is
beautiful and say that you're still too
heavy
that's okay you're too heavy you're fat
you're beautiful you can you know
whatever you're just you just weigh too
much that's all it is just
let's say you're too ugly to ride the
horse no i have an idea here's the
solution let one of the other skills
models ride you right there
problem solved you get to participate i
mean if i run a ranch and you know aoc
comes in i wouldn't deny her service but
i would make her wear a specific outfit
so i could you know tell her in the
horse part
they should give them two horses
yes make them feel bad yeah they're like
oh you're right we got something for you
you have to lay across two saddles right
you feel good yeah you're roped down
yeah enjoy your ride and instead of
putting your feet you're gonna have to
ratchet one of those stirrups around you
like uh like liam neeson in the gray
when the plane goes down
[Laughter]
yeah it's called the wolves win the
movie
whiskey for my man fat [ __ ] for my
horses now oh
cares oh my gosh why do you want to ride
a horse
you got cars
it was a free benefit but it's also
it's probably dangerous for her to do
outright and breaking fences
[Laughter]
why don't you come to your senses
you've been running through fences with
your fat ass now
you're disgusting
oh that's just what people say
i don't know there's extra fruit by the
foot in your glove box
you better let a diet love you
before ain't nobody gonna love you
two oh it is too late because of your
weight
it's too late we're taking the feet of
course people can love you of course
good news you lost both your legs you
can ride the horse exactly people anyone
is worthy
is this the sugar foot thing though yeah
again that's old sugar foot ranch type 2
ranch yes
why do you only have one stirrup yeah
well
and i
just have a statue of wilford brimley
are these shoes for sale on the horse
yeah you can buy them thank you
all right i want these sandals those are
stirrups well they fit perfect love them
fine
okay
you're very strange person
please leave i just look this is the
problem this is it seems like it's silly
but guess what we just had this where we
yeah we can be banned on youtube if we
refer to someone who's very clearly a
man as a man
and we oh that's right recently we were
labeled medical misinformation for the
fat pride panel that i crashed back at
south by southwest that was labeled
medical misinformation you know who did
because i asked him about the health
problems associated with being obese and
they got furious that was labeled we'll
have that screenshot tomorrow because it
probably went through my lawyer it was
labeled medical misinformation i had to
go back and watch it and say there's
literally nothing in here that could be
medical it's medical information yeah
just take away the mess yeah i hate that
we have we say this all the time the
problem isn't fat people the problem is
fat people who say that that is a
healthy lifestyle promote that to people
which is what this person is essentially
doing yeah and please say fat because
obese is offensive yes obese is
offensive how is fat okay and obese is
not you know what we prefer the term
gross now
[Laughter]
share the show sweaty
share the show uh if you're watching our
youtube hit the share button because you
know a lot of people saw you i
appreciate it you'll be watching crowder
bits but a lot of people miss all of
this information here in the show so you
can tune in that always helps because uh
youtube algorithm doesn't it doesn't
help us or pay us anything all right hey
one one quick update uh the supreme
court is releasing opinions right now so
if roe v wade comes up we'll break that
for you live on oh i thought you were
going to say this
this fat horse scenario got kicked up to
the supreme court not yet
but we'll break that too nope that's
still uh still too heavy to ride they
got forklifted to the supreme court
the horse walks in it's just like please
please don't let her right
i already have back problems keep us
free
horses
learning to speak to save their own
lives all right he's trying to pull a
toe trigger with a hoof yes
that's sad because he could never get it
no it's just gonna be no you know he has
the right to take himself out
call courtney love she'll do it you know
clydesdale forest in japan
now
[Laughter]
one of the paul brothers just walks
through with
um
question for you we talked about this
earlier have you heard people say now
they didn't used to they didn't always
used to say this and i guarantee you
they won't be saying this when naturally
gas prices will probably go down at some
point it seems unlikely have you been
told one of two things either the
president doesn't have any effect on gas
prices or the president doesn't control
gas prices or there's more drilling
taking place actually under under
former vice president biden then under
donald trump that's something that we
hear a lot of yeah i heard it on cnn
this morning here's the problem
no so
for those of you who don't know because
you may live in some states where you
actually have decent gas prices and by
decent i mean horrible but not you know
swallow a gun horrible
it's now reached across the country over
five dollars a gallon as of saturday i
think saturday june 11. yeah there you
go
for the first time ever the average
price of gas nationwide has hit an
unprecedented five dollars a gallon but
for drivers in california that price is
still a bargain
she sounds so happy about it for
for citizens in california it's a good
thing they won't need fuel to keep warm
yeah by the way citizens of california
you haven't seen five dollars a gallon
in decades have you
meaning it's well above yeah i'm alex
taking all the gas for his avocado ranch
this is my first high gas rodeo no it's
no i've been here before so let's go
through some of the why is this why are
gas prices so high and i know that you
inherently this is one of the things
people inherently know i know we had
eight years of obama then we had three
years of donald trump i don't really
count the fourth year that's what i call
the last year because of the the
fabricated government reaction to the
pandemic then we have
joe biden it's really valuable eight
three and we're going to have four
high gas prices record low gas prices
high gas prices again so you probably
inherently know that it has something to
do with the former vice president but
they've been trying to convince you that
it doesn't and let me give you some
information just so you you know what's
wrong all references available at
lightworkcredit.com here is a claim that
they are currently making you will hear
this gas prices are only high right now
because of what russia russia russia the
average price of gas nationally today
hit five dollars a gallon for the first
time what's your message to the american
people especially as we head into the
summer months
really struggling with this this is
outrageous what the war
and ukraine is causing
okay i love that it's putin's price
heights it's russia's problem for oil
prices come on joe well
here's the truth is the majority of the
gas price hikes took place before russia
they were on a steep upward trend just
it looks steep yes
geez
about as
steep as the uh the right angle in the
horse's back after that rider a black
diamond hill
but there aren't even moguls it's just a
straight no it's just yeah there's no
bumps no bumps um now uh so the majority
took place before russia you know that
and i know that and that might change by
the way because the prices are going to
continually rise and that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's because of
russia they were going up before russia
they'll continue to go up uh the federal
reserve bank of st louis it clearly
shows that there was an increase before
the invasion you have that chart right
there okay here's another truth since
january 18th
uh 2021 biden has and this is important
to note because people say well
the president doesn't have control over
gas prices it's actually probably one of
the issues where they have more control
than most people and that's because oil
in particular petroleum is a highly
speculative market what do i mean by
that sometimes you say well hold on it
doesn't have to do with supply and
demand it has very much to do with
regarding prices projections yeah right
you're talking about future earnings and
so really really helps determine whether
you're going to drill whether you're
going to pull back you will see a rubber
band effect sometimes depending on when
someone comes into office where gas
prices go down just because of policies
that may not be enacted for another year
or two because they're willing to invest
knowing that they'll recoup it so that
being said
former vice president biden has taken
over 80 actions
impacting what would impact gas prices
fossil fuels largely against them and
here's the thing are you really
surprised i know people will argue this
and say well there's more to it look
look look again the rhetoric matters
when that directly affects the market
here is former vice president uh biden
in his run-up in the election he was
clear i just want to give him a chance
to respond that we can come back
we're staying on this issue number one
no more subsidies for fossil fuel
industry no more drilling on federal
lands no more drilling including
offshore no ability for the oil industry
to continue to drill period ends number
one
commit to the responsible phase out
fossil fuel production as part of your
administration i guarantee you i
guarantee you we're going to end fossil
fuel and i am not going to cooperate
with you okay
now before we get to the executive
actions you work for a fossil fuel
company i'll just tell you this let's
say the president
said i guarantee you i guarantee you i
will end louder with crowder
what do you think i would do i would say
i've probably got another year or until
the next till the next tax day
where i get an auditing that destroys me
uh i'm gonna pull back and save my money
right now am i going to invest am i
going to hire more people am i going to
expand no would i start drilling more no
would i invest in more equipment no
would i make more hires no of course not
you wouldn't increase the supply you
would reduce it because you try and
collect the profits that you can because
it's a limited window when he says in no
uncertain terms i'm going to end it now
let's look at his 80 executive actions
that he has taken by the way um
i believe it was it was uh yeah 80
actions i don't know how many of them
are executive orders but a lot of them
are exactly yeah these are actions so uh
here's one paris climate accord he
decided to join that paris climate
accord which by the way does nothing to
curb china's emissions nope and
and they matter right they'll get right
on that he revokes the keystone xl
pipeline to be clear sometimes they'll
try and tell you that well keystone has
already done keystone xl is different
from keystone yep uh he supported
increases of 230 billion dollars in
taxes on oil he reinstated the social
cost of carbon metric some of the
executive orders there's uh day one the
climate change order you have on january
27th climate financing you have on is
this may 20th climate financial risk
then you have um
is this uh december 8th december 8th
clean energy economy 100 electric
electric vehicle fleet by 2035. that's
before elon musk wanted to buy twitter
now he's like i hope he gets to the moon
yeah
so
it's very clear look you have to look at
these actions all going one way
and the claim that they're making of
course that's going to affect the market
now here's another claim good tim uh
and they'll say this well it's it's a
it's a bounce back from covid right
that's what's happening it's a bounce
back now because more people are driving
because they weren't driving in covid
here's the truth okay
there's no actual data that would
suggest that at all i think we have an
overlay right here you can see the
before and after covet kicked off it was
still hovering right around 250 a gallon
yeah that's not where the steep increase
took place yeah and it matters so when
people talk about the the policies not
mattering on like a keystone or
something like that or paris climate
accord like you said if you pull
supply from the market globally that the
united states was able to produce or was
able to produce in the future in a
couple of years with keystone right if
you pull that supply from the market
that means the prices are going to go up
people are going to say oh there's not
going to be as much oil available in the
market which means prices have to go up
right or or we have to increase capacity
significantly we have not had a good
track record of getting opec to play
ball in the past they do kind of what
they want to do which is why joe biden
is going hat in hand to saudi arabia and
other middle eastern countries and also
to venezuela
well yeah
he does need more his hat
it's a porta potty really but that's why
he's doing it so people say that say he
has no impact on this have no idea how
this works and the white house did say
thank god that they're going to be
releasing more oil from the strategic
petroleum reserve which is really for
times of war so that we can make sure
that we can fight oh we're at war it's a
proxy war with ukraine russia yeah we're
kind of you know send them 40 billion
basically i think in this release it's
maybe you know a couple of million
barrels that that'll do what i think a
few hours worth of american
consumption another problem not solved
no that he also takes no responsibility
for right and here's and that's
important because here's another claim
that they make and this is the one that
you hear everywhere right now because
they know that it's okay check mate if
it's not true and americans inherently
believe that their claim is not true so
they just repeat it repeat it repeat it
repeat it repeat it just like you know
safest most secure election in history
so they're claiming right now that
there's actually more domestic drilling
under former vice president joe biden
then president trump that's what they're
claiming
no okay so let me explain to you that's
the truth no let me explain to you uh
and this is one of those areas where
nuance does matter but
it can be distilled it's pretty simple
actually the total number of permits
issued under biden in 2021 it was higher
than trump's highest year okay so biden
first year was 4 800 drilling permits
right in 2021 trump was 4 600 46 31 in
uh 2020.
now here's the thing
the permits issued
are for leases sold mostly under trump
think of them remember rollover minutes
they're rollover leases
and then if you look at the trend as
expected the bide administration slash
the approvals for drilling by august of
last year so look at that chart they go
look look there are more permits because
donald trump was basically on his way to
set a record year of permits
then biden came in
there were these permits that he
couldn't necessarily stop boom slash
them if you actually look on a month to
month the month where this was uh where
this was being slashed in august guess
what it's very very different than the
months preceding it yeah this is
important but the thing is when they
were campaigning right because they have
to this is what you see with the left
they have to be dishonest about their
their positions because they've got to
appeal to the abortion up until nine
months of including birth period they've
got to appeal to the green new deal
crowd they've got to appeal to the crowd
that turns off for example latino vote
voters so he has to say i will end
fossil fuels then when they get into
office they have to govern more
moderately why because americans often
and sometimes this is unfortunate vote
with their pocketbook it's really hard
to vote against your own self-interest
even if you are principled and in this
case you just ha it's serendipitous
because the two line up you can vote
your principles and you can vote your
pocketbook so then he gets into office
we go from i'm going to end fossil fuels
to now things are so bad they're making
the claim and fossil fuels there's more
drilling uh under me than under donald
trump well yeah that's because of the
first half of the year which you then
stopped right and he did it for show not
just for the american voters but he did
it that slash in august i think it would
sound like 170 permits basically in that
month right he did it in advance of
going to a climate summit exactly he's
basically trying to show the world look
see i'm doing my part guys right this is
what happens he's coming into office and
at the end of last year the oil company
said holy crap these leases are two
years they usually come with a two-year
automatic renewal if they apply for it
right they're going we have to get
leases because this guy's gonna shut it
down right the white house's response to
all this is to continue to taper it off
and go as low as they possibly can and
then say like you said more but here's
the thing they just issued a statement
today
saying the oil company ceos this was a
threat from biden to the ceos right
increase production and stop price
gouging he's now blaming them you know
what capacity is right now it's over 90
we're roughly at about the same level we
were in like 2015 2016. that's not a
problem by the way that's important to
note because let's do that math right
okay more permits total because of what
happened under donald trump and what
happened those last six months but we're
at capacity what does that tell you
they're sitting on the leases
because they don't want to develop it
they don't want to develop they're not
actually implementing the capabilities
to drill why because that's very
expensive
and
this guy may or may not end fossil fuels
keep in mind
it's not i'm not a fan it's not let's
find a middle ground let's do it i'm
going to imagine if someone walked into
any office any company and just said i
will end you and then said can't we find
common ground
[Applause]
i don't know you're pretty emphatic
about that whole ending me stuff yeah
exactly well and it's his threat to the
uh ceos he basically pulled like a mel
gibson who's like you're a terrible
person but i will give you one more
chance i will give you one more this is
this thing he basically said i he
threatened to enact war powers executive
powers given to the president for times
of war for war production right he said
i will do this
but maybe we can come up with some
solutions maybe you guys maybe you guys
have some ideas on how to increase
capacity yeah it's like you don't just
turn this off and on if you look at a
chart which was linked in the article if
you look at a chart it shows you when
covet hit it was a slow trickle down
because demand went down very quickly
yeah after it ended it was a slow
trickle up and then in december of this
last year it trickled down just a little
bit more that's why they're making more
profits they had excess capacity so that
excess expenses that they were paying
out and not making anything and they
didn't know they were gonna be falling
off a cliff when joe biden said no more
drilling
it's just it's stupid none of these
arguments are honest and people like
robert reich out there saying that oh
this is just price gouging no it's not
robert reich really hates i hate that
guy because he didn't ask the question
he's out there
spewing this crap
going on cnn and saying that these
things are true and it's not true no
it's not true not at all true no none of
this is true so the idea is is it russia
no absolutely not it was kovid
no claimed ukraine yes he blamed
fairness
mostly the ukrainians most of the
ukrainian people getting attacked by
russians yeah something also about 40
billion dollars that i don't know we
couldn't use here in the united states
they don't need that money and then
there's more drilling under joe biden
than under donald trump well okay you
know what if politifact and these people
were being honest they'd say well that's
partially true but that's because of the
rollover from donald trump and then joe
biden has boom basically put a
moratorium he's actually cut the
drilling so if someone tries to present
that to you all references are available
at letterworthcredor.com i know this is
what is being presented right now it is
arrogant from the left there are more
drilling permits under under biden
they don't actually understand economics
they don't actually understand what's
happening with the oil industry and they
don't understand what
there's a huge difference between hard
goods and services and a market that is
largely based on speculation which by
the way supporters of speculative
markets they tend to overwhelmingly give
money to democrats just to be clear big
banks democrats you know how to fix this
though
one of the ways that you fix this is say
okay you want to speculate on oil prices
and drive them up or drive them down
investors take delivery
this was developed for oil companies to
make sure that they could have supply
and make sure our system wasn't
interrupted that's who it's for when
speculators drive up prices which they
can do sometimes yes just say okay you
have to take delivery
yeah in your manhattan 1 000 square foot
apartment that cost you seven million
dollars
good that's why it sucks okay dave
is going to be this friday in grand
junction colorado then him and i are
live of course colorado springs i think
we have if you want to buy your tickets
i don't know if we just go to
lightroom.com tour there are a couple
that we're keeping available to walk up
because some of you are actually driving
and walking yeah there's not much on the
side i was checking today i don't think
there's anything but there might be
might be releasing some walk ups on the
day if you walk from out of state yeah
you'll get a ticket well yeah but also
you can't afford the gas so we're going
to play what's in the box and tomorrow
cultural appropriation month have your
costumes ready for taiwan youtube you're
never going to know what's in this box
only mug club piss off
you